نعم قبل قليل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه دمرت عددا من منازل المواطنين
في حي الدعوه شمال مخيم النصيرات للاجئين
وسط قطاع غزه اي الطائرات الحربيه شنت
سلسله من الغارات الجويه بعدد من الصواريخ
ودمرت هذه المنازل تدميرا كليا في هذه
المنطقه القريبه من محور الاشتباك مع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مدخل الشرقي
لمدينه دير البلح بالاضافه الى الاشتباكات
المتواصله داخل مخيم المغازي وايضا في
منطقه الزوايده الحديث والمناشدات التي
ترد من المواطنين في مخيم مغازي على وجه
التحديد هناك عشرات العائلات التي ما زالت
محاصره داخل منازلها ولا تستطيع الخروج
منها او الخروج من المخيم الى منطقه امنه
نتيجه تواصل الاشتباكات والقصف المدفعي
وايضا الجوي من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالا باضافه الى وجود عدد من
الشهداء وعشرات الجرحى داخل المنازل في
مخيم المغازي لا تستطيع طواقم الاسعاف
الوصول اليها لانتشال جثامين الشهداء
وايضا انقاذ حياه الجرحى والوصول بهم الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح هذا
المستشفى الذي يعاني اوضاع كارثيه خلال
الساعات الاخيره مع الاعلام عن انقطاع
التيار الكهرباء عن جميع مرافقه نتيجه
نفاد الوقود وسط مناشدات من وزاره الصح
ومن اداره المستشفى للمنظمات الامميه
ومنظمه الصحه العالميه على وجه التحديد
بضروره تزويده بالوقود اللازمه لتشغيل
المولدات الكهربائيه خاصه وان هناك المئات
من الجرحى داخل غرف العنايه المكثفه
بالاضافه الى ان هناك عشرات العمليات
الجراحيه المجدوله لانقاذ حياه الجرحى
الذين يصلون بالمئات يوميا الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى وفي ظل الاشتباكات والقصف
العنيف الذي تشهده المحافظه الوسطى بجميع
مخيماتها خلال الايام الاخيره هنا في
مدينه خان يونس لازال القصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي يستهدف مختلف المناطق في
المدينه وتحديدا في المحور الجنوبي الشرقي
من المدينه بالاضافه الى البلدات والمناطق
التي تشهد اشتباكات شرقي محافظه خانيونس
وسط تحليق مكثف لطائرات الاستطلاع
الاسرائيليه على ارتفاعات منخفضه في اجواء
مدينه خانيونس في رفح كانت شهدت الغاره
الاعنف من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه والتي دمرت منزلا على رؤوس
ساكنيه هذا المنزل كان يؤوي نازحين من
عائله ابو الاشين الذين نزحوا من منطقه
الزويده الى مدينه رفع على اعتبار ان هذه
المدينه امنه كما يدعي جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لان الصواريخ الحربيه
الاسرائيليه لاحقتهم داخل هذا المنزل الذي
اووا اليه ما ادى الى ارتقاء عشره من
الشهداء بينهم عدد من الاطفال الى جانب
عشرات الجرحى الذين وصلوا الى مستشفى ابو
يوسف النجار وبحسب المصادر الطبيه فان
عددا من هؤلاء الجرحى هم جراحهم خطيره